this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
for me this is mostly a conversation
like i don't i don't i'm not if you go
on my channel you won't find debates
it's mostly about exploring ideas and
exploring uh and i think that
i think that there's a um
i think that there's an interesting
bridge for people
in the west that are interested in in
esotericism uh in general
with
just really mainstream uh orthodox
theology where it's more integrated in
the west there seems to have been
a schism somewhere in the late middle
ages where you know the elites kind of
went up towards these these
these esoteric uh
groups and esoteric uh societies uh and
then the catholic church
was kind of
was kind of left down there and then
finally it ended up being a hostile
relationship between the two sides but i
feel like in the east there's a more
integrated version and so i talk about
symbolism i talk about
mystery i talk we talk about all these
things about you know becoming god the
deification of of man and i have no
problem with my hierarchy at all like i
have no there's no
i have no pushback because it's
basically just the common thing so i
don't know if you know a little bit
about eastern christianity
i've i've studied a little bit about it
but not quite so much i think
catholicism is more accessible with
regards to their traditions and a lot of
literature that i've encountered
uh the orthodox thing is as far as being
a major force in
the english-speaking world i think is
more recent
generally speaking most of my forte
though a lot of it really deals with the
occult at large in the sense of folklore
superstition things like that like as
far as esotericism of any brand it
really focuses more on that i have more
of an appreciation for the what we would
conceive of as the vulgar actually uh
more of an interest in that folk charms
and rituals including some christian
mysticism it was often uh in the works
that i've actually edited a lot of it is
at the very least a facade an
overlapping of christendom and praise
jesus over
what would otherwise be considered as
heretical magic actually as well
and that's quite common this is even in
hermetic works this is in works that are
even certainly the alchemical works a
lot of them are chemical preparations
but they're uh basically coded and they
talk about angels and spirits and
different divine ideas and figures sort
of as a facade to hide the chemical
recipe and also
a lot of the works masquerade as
chemical recipes but they're really
spiritual polemics
i find that fascinating
and so you're mostly interested in the
application like the the the magic part
let's see
yeah and and folklore in general
religious history i just got done
editing a work on the babylonian and
syrian customs um not just the occult
side of it although it was especially in
babylon intertwined with everything but
uh
even their weights and measures it was
funny uh
in babylon when they when they study
their cuneiform tablets uh they find a
lot of personal correspondence a lot of
it's actually kind of funny it's like
between lovers or between neighbors
legal suits then assyria takes over and
it's almost entirely military and
diplomatic in nature and i find that
aspect of the human experience to be
fascinating
and so i i guess like my question would
be
to you what do you think happened in
the west that created
that created these kind of schisms let's
say in terms of esotericism but also in
terms of uh of of uh
even the the definition of magic as it
came to be in the early modern the early
modern era
i i think it's intertwined a lot with
civics and deals with with more secular
authorities too there was an interesting
schism actually between the the catholic
and protestant uh groups in terms of the
burning times in terms of persecuting
people for folk magic or herbalism or
whatever the catholics had a caveat well
if you can establish that it's just
white magic you're just healing people
you know you're not you're not causing
abortions and you're not doing black
magic
they weren't burned at the stake or or
drowned or anything in the protestant
tradition allah king james demonology of
course which you probably read um they
didn't care if you if you were doing any
folk magic and it wasn't explicitly
canonical explicitly uber christian uh
you were a witch anyway and would get
killed for that
yeah and so do you think it has also to
do with the kind of burgeoning of
scientism that happened at that time
because a lot of people tend to
this is one of the things i always face
is people tell me you know the medieval
witch burnings i'm like medieval
whisperings like which burnings are
early modern although they're
renaissance exactly
and so there's like there's this there's
this
birth of the scientific mind which wants
to categorize things in terms of just in
terms of technical and in terms of
quantitative things and so they face
these practices which are
different let's say and that are more
related to
spiritual influence you could say or
influence of the person that is
performing the
the remedy uh and they don't know what
to do with it so so it's like it doesn't
fit in this kind of like enlightenment
version of christianity yeah and the the
really weird part is that the middle
ages were less persecutory in some ways
than the renaissance and everyone says
well things got better during the
renaissance everything was maybe science
and technology clockwork mainly uh and
actually in the middle ages there was
less of that i edited another work
recently on medieval medicine and one of
the main things discussed is uh in the
renaissance
you have uh sort of a reversion to the
more antiquated notion that the sickness
was invariably spiritual in nature
whereas in the middle ages there was at
least some attempt to say well yes i
believe in demons and demons of sickness
are definitely causing problems but also
you know you've got these humors and
it's not necessarily a demon maybe you
just ate the wrong food
they didn't have germ theory but they
had a basic concept of the
transmissibility of disease and it
almost disappears actually later on it's
almost strange how there was a
retrogression in medicine
there's also an interesting one of the
interesting things that i discovered was
that
uh i would see in the roman times there
was a kind of witch-burning that was
popular and then
charlemagne actually
was one of the people that banned the
burning of witches he said you know like
this the witches don't exist basically
it's what he was saying like this is
just like you know let's not bother
people with this uh and then it came
back like you said towards the late
middle ages and ultimately especially
during the renaissance and kind of in
this these weird kind of witch scares
and werewolf scares it happen at that
time
oh yeah werewolves is another funny
thing yeah the babylonians used to do
that they they used to have specifically
like medicine men you could call them
they were intertwined with the
priesthood actually that would dispense
little spells and give people like
little items to put next to their door
to keep witches away led by lily to
actually they're sort of a queen of the
damned if you will that informs lilith
later on in judeo-christian tradition
and uh it's actually funny because they
imagine that this horde of demons went
out at night along with the transients
and and pickpockets and prostitutes
actually and they were sort of all
lumped together and they they would uh
get paid to have
protective spells and incantations
against them and we die it's funny
because uh in in the middle ages you see
less of that i've i've edited grimars
and most of them they're not from the
middle ages from the renaissance or even
the enlightenment and there is where you
get some of the classical sort of takes
on on witchcraft miasmas and stuff like
burning a wolf skull with herbs in it at
the edge of the village to keep the
plague away and things like that even
though the black death predates that by
many centuries
one of the things that i'm curious about
because i've been to i talked to about
this with a uh a professor of many of uh
byzantine studies and
i was trying to understand because a lot
of the texts that informed the
renaissance magic some of them obviously
came from you know from from spain but
many of them came from constantinople as
constantinople was kind of taken by the
the muslims a lot of the scholars left
constantinople for the for the west
like the corpus hermeticum was preserved
in constantinople basically but there it
doesn't see it didn't seem to have the
same effect
and so i was we're trying to figure out
like in constantinople towards the end
there were all these neoplatonus there
were the the the hermeticists you know
and they're all there
uh but it didn't create this schism
which we see
happening in the west as modernism kind
of uh sets itself up it could have been
like a neo-roman appreciation for the
compilation of knowledge
sort of thing like just having the
material there was considered comfy and
and enlightening just having access to
it maybe more than an actual sub
movement
maybe
yeah but i think there were people that
were practicing and reading it it just
wasn't it didn't create a kind of social
disruption as it did as it is it moved
into italy let's say um and and you see
boccaccio and all these people kind of
taking it up um anyway so
to me that's it's curious like i'm
trying to figure i'm a western person
right and so i'm always trying to figure
out what is it that happened in the west
so that you come to the 18th century
19th century and you have these like
free masonic these freemasons and these
rosy christians or whatever uh and then
you have popular culture and what
like what broke like how is it that that
these
things became
became so separated and so i don't know
if you have if you're interested about
more info folk religion maybe you don't
have insight on that but if you do i'd
love to hear it
not so much insight but maybe the the
disruption was greater because those
greater powers including the the
ottomans and other groups held things
together more than the smaller
inter-warring states that comprised
western europe for a lot of that period
maybe
because i mean if they're constantly
changing land you know one day you're
flying one flag the next day you're
flying another you're going to have more
authoritarian
civics you're going to have kings that
are more strong arm as opposed to having
a greater expanse and you have
sub-governors and stuff and there's
maybe more tolerance it's funny the
ottomans were butcherous and insane in
many ways but religious tolerance
arguably was higher under the ottoman
empire at most points than it was in the
west
well yeah just because they also were
like in the same way that the west kind
of tolerated jews then the muslims
tolerated jews and christians it was
like
what comes after it tolerates the thing
that they're replacing for yeah i think
i think the jews mainly in the in the
plague times i think mainly migrated to
poland if i remember correctly
yeah i mean there's a huge
for sure foreign
uh and so so another question that i had
of you
is
how does it translate today like
because you study all these books and
everything and you call yourself a pagan
like how does it translate into the
modern world like how do you
practice these things like do you ha
like is it is there like animal
sacrifices like something like that no
that's that's that's that's mainly a
jewish and islamic tradition more than
it is genuinely pagan
when we see mention of mass animal
sacrifices a lot of them they come from
like the mesopotamian pagan cultures and
things like that are ancient greece
most people i i don't think do that
fortunately that's really just a take
off of fortune telling i think there's
been a co-development a co-evolution of
the practice of divination especially
because it used to be you needed to buy
the oxen slaughter it read its entrails
or you needed to offer
two goats to the priest or or do
something that was expensive and or
possibly dangerous and it was simplified
over time to become more user-friendly
you can call that a devolution in the
sense that it's no longer the authentic
original tradition but if we were to
live a world today where you had maybe
like a sumerian style animal sacrifice
then uh the price of beef would be a
little bit higher than just under
bidenomics
yeah we killed we killed all of our cows
every single year we always knew what
the future would hold in the future held
that we wouldn't have hamburgers anymore
then american culture would collapse
and so how does it translate like i'm
curious to know like how it translates
well
with my editing in my study mostly it's
more on the academic side
to tell the truth my own personal
practice i rely upon i believe in dream
interpretation in the loose sense
although there are a million different
methods to interpret it this is
something that's common i think pretty
much to every religion there are
christians that
dabble in that even if they say well
well yeah i'm interpreting the dream but
god gave me insight or something it's a
mystic experience it's in judaism
certainly in islam
it's in hinduism etc um that
i believe in in basic oracle usage again
it's a fortune telling methodology uh
you can use a random number generator
for that for what it's worth uh but
mainly it's an academic interest
uh initially i don't know if i've
mentioned this to you before but my
editing started simply because i saw
that there was a huge amount of
literature
available about the occult in general
all subtopics and on amazon but people
were taking pdf scans of initial
documents great for primary source work
but a lot of them they're dog-eared
they're missing pages there's
grammatical mistakes there's writing in
some of these things and they're
charging 20 30 for them i'm sitting
there as a poor person i'm like now i'd
love to read these books in an actual
print copy but i can't even afford more
than one or two of them and i said i set
about getting the original digital scans
and completely re-editing them to make
them in a modern format and lowered the
price sometimes yeah the prices are
pretty low
yeah yeah by three or four times and
what i wanted to do is say this is is
literature that's valuable in some cases
there may be only two or three paper
copies of these works i've stumbled
across mention of works that are
apparently extinct there's supposedly a
fortune teller from the early 1800s that
was ascribed to thomas jefferson i've
seen it mentioned in a couple of other
works i've never run across any
information on a copy mm-hmm and i am
also a bibliophile i love physical books
so i don't want them to go extinct and i
might as well make a living off of it in
the meantime
is that your main source of like living
is the is the book editing
yeah i make more off of the book editing
than i do on donations and things like
that and youtube stuff yeah yeah um and
so what like what value do you think it
brings us these books like
as modern people
well if if someone's interested
academically they can study it if
someone's interested in certain paths or
ideas within the occult they can
actually utilize them that i mean i keep
them in their original format
occasionally i redact sections like a
lot of these works had lengthy lists of
advertisements at the end especially the
herbal works for like this miracle tonic
this will make your hair grow back and
and you know stuff like that and it's
just like only occasionally do i include
any of that sometimes the index would be
mispaged so i'll take that out otherwise
i keep them intact and the idea is that
people can study from them people can
use them maybe they just want it you
know in some cases someone's a fan of
mine they just want something that i
edited so
yeah make it available
i mean i think i'm kind of pushing you
in the sense that
so you know obviously everything's in
crisis i think that you probably noticed
that for several years that there's a
crisis in the west you could say there's
a crisis of meaning there's a crisis of
identity there's a crisis
in education there's a crisis just
constantly there's a problem with
commies yeah yeah exactly
uh and so
i think that i guess where i'm going to
is like
one of the crises is a spiritual crisis
you could call it like there's a there's
a
and it manifests itself in the in all
kinds of stuff whether it's a it's
these weird kind of literalist
evangelicals whether it is the the
breakdown into like new age mushy
whatever stuff that that that is out
there crystals and all this kind of
crystals are fun
they opened a sorcery school uh like two
streets for me and it's like it's like a
witchcraft school it's obviously so
wickens in other words i don't know what
they are they they probably go out back
they probably go out back and dance
topless twice a year and then they take
some mushrooms and play with their
amethyst i by the way
inauthentic religion like that
it can be cringy but it's harmless and
there are some people out there still
think wiccans worship the devil and like
you gotta read the a book on hedge wicca
sometimes basically they just want to
grow and drink tea all day
yeah i mean it's like it's like a weird
it's like a weird modern union kind of
uh real imagination and
100 years old gardener all he wanted to
do was see naked priestesses
yeah i'm not surprised that that's what
we behind it so so the idea is like
there's this crisis uh and so
so when i look at
like let's say when i look at the
popularity of narcissism right now and
the popularity of all these all these
kind of resurgence of all these weird
texts and all this weird stuff i see it
as part of the breakdown like i see it
as a scattering of of stuff where
everything is kind of breaking down and
and fragmenting into into different uh
into different kind of idiosyncratic you
mean like the availability of like a
cult literature and stuff like that or
well not the availability just the fact
that
joe whatever like joe next to next door
you know is
talking to me about kabbalah as if
like as if this has anything to do like
as if and then and then he mixes it with
aliens
and then he mixes it with like all this
kind of modern stuff and you're like
it just seems like it's poor it's like a
huge yeah
yeah but that's already happened anyway
all the religious practices of today
pretty much are a bric-a-brac because of
the cosmopolitan nature of post-colonial
trade and travel i i would say arguably
the one other than the orthodoxy which
is more puristic in that sense another
one and i actually thought to mention
this to you because i was thinking back
to when we were having our our debate
actually there is one other mystically
inclined religion that hasn't changed
form at least you know the the
scriptures and stuff are still there you
can practice it authentically hinduism
yeah it's just hard because to be a
hindu you have to be in a in a cast so
it's like it's hard to become an indian
i know people that become hindus and it
just feels like it's
it's bogus to me
yeah i i would actually actually debate
that point too the the caste system
initially doesn't really have to do with
with birth and do a specific situation
by parentage it has to do with being
judged on one's traits thereafter like
once yeah but who would attribute you to
a cast like how who would decide well
well it's canonical the way in which
that's done it depends on what you're
geared towards your your personality and
so forth if you if you actually go
through
not just the bhagavad gita but all their
other various texts uh that that part
actually is still authentic
that's more the indian state and i think
what happened is that the people at the
top who tended to be brahmana uh said
hey we've got a good thing going
we'll just make it about who your
parents were we'll have all of this
fortune and stuff will be the raja
forever
and then again that's a civic
denigration of what was originally a
more spiritually minded thing yeah have
you ever thought about the relationship
between the varna
and like the cat the basic cat system
and the medieval
caste system it's almost identical
in the in the medieval world they had
those that pray those that fight and
those that work so it was three it was a
three-tiered system and it wasn't also
necessarily completely based on births
obviously because the the uh the
priestly cast wasn't a
it's not a it's not a cast that was uh
that that could be transmitted because
of the that's almost similar to plato's
description of how to describe to people
why there are differences between
cultural groups like saying oh well you
know the
people were formed out of different
metals and so the the ruler he's the
ruler because he was made out of gold
when he was born you're a merchant
because you're made out of copper you're
a soldier because you're made out of
iron and you you're a homeless because
you were made out of the dirt under my
shoe
and it's funny because actually julius
caesar uh in the roman days reforms this
initially the roman columns are very
much like the greek hoplite uh and were
taken from the ranks of the nobility and
caesar said well we need more men
because we've got all these barbarians
we've got to kill and then he started
going out to like the farmlands and
finding the big brawny dudes that were
working all day anyway and drafting them
be making them centaurions and stuff
yeah turning them into soldiers yeah i
mean caesar was obviously much more
pragmatic more revolutionary than we
sometimes want to to to see him as let's
say um but so my question is like
what do you see as the as some let's say
some of the solutions to the to the the
crisis meeting and so i'll be totally
honest with you like to me
you know spending many years thinking
and looking and everything i see that
christianity for the west
that's that's it like there's no
everything else that's presenting itself
is presenting itself as a destructuring
agent it's presenting itself as
something that is increasing the
breakdown uh and that
the solution that i that i kind of
grabbed onto was to restore the mystical
possib not myself but to go back into
the mystical possibilities of
christianity like dive back into the
early church fathers and the you know
the the latter towards heaven all of
these these types of descriptions of
mythical transformation uh rather than
kind of go into all this stuff that was
boiling up and so obviously that's not
the solution you grabbed onto so my
question is what do you see as
like a spiritual
path for the west or a spiritual
possibility i i think that it's about
the the individual and that it's
cosmopolitan in nature i don't see that
as a breakdown of anything other than an
order that wasn't initial to the united
states certainly in elements of the west
because those were promulgated by
something you could roughly say it was
an amalgamation of christian lore but in
the deistic sense generally
secular authority the civic structure
and then elements of maybe the more
enlightened pagan groups that had
already been studied especially in
greece rome and to an extent egypt and
those things those ideas amalgamated
together they did in the middle ages as
well as we've already gone over
and they formed a backbone to society
that was much stronger it really isn't
in the united states for example until
the the
1830s 1840s that you get a resurgence of
two of these forces trying to break that
that sort of backbone you get the
rationalists the secular side of things
like well god is dead you know screw you
shouldn't have this religion stuff it's
boring and then you get the the hyper
fire and brimstone especially protestant
groups in the us i know the orthodoxy
doesn't engage in that quite so much but
among the protestants it was a big thing
i would say also christianity is also
already schism
um we have the protestants and they've
subscribed into a million groups you've
got catholics you get the orthodoxy you
got like the newer groups like mormons
which are arguably vaguely christian in
some ways jehovah's witnesses and then
other groups and then you have and we
spoke about this too the absorption of
uh of foreign matter into various forms
of christendom forming new age movements
you know scientology arguably to an
extent the
a thousand cults mostly based in the la
area you know because california is a
cult uh
and uh but but i don't see this as a
problem
because that
sort of diversity of thought on the
secular level was already there and then
was a good thing i think that people by
and large should simply study as many
spiritual systems as possible and arrive
at their own conclusions but in order
for that to happen they have to have
uh self-awareness and they have to have
rational critical thinking the problem
is that mainstream religion is the only
thing that's going to work for the
masses because the masses don't have the
time or the intelligence or the
inclination to study these things for
them i've been approached by people
asking me for spiritual advice and what
i tell them is if you want to put a lot
of effort into it
delve into everything just go ahead
study it's all there you can get it for
free digitally because of the wonder of
the internet
if you're not inclined in that direction
shop around for a mainstream religion
and just uh make sure not to follow any
cult leaders
exactly but so what do you think is the
vector of
like what's the vector of unity like
what stops
what stops the u.s or what stops the
west from just being invaded from the
outside like what makes us something
you mean in what sense invaded
ideologically physically both either
whatever like that you vanish as
something like you just because
physically it's it's your military
capability and your will to guard your
borders so the former we've got down pat
the latter as a work in progress or
redress at the moment under beijing
biden's administration and others uh
trudeau up there uh as a little bit
divisive himself i'd say a lot of the
divisiveness though is the misuse of
spiritual systems by civic forces that
as governments have understood now that
if they divide people it's easier to
control them and abuse them and take
more of their money and religion is a
great vector for that at this point i
think race and artificial identity like
the lgbtqa plus xyz thing
are the main things but religion is
still alluded to
even in the united states think about
this way
joe biden reigns over a party that harps
about secularism but every time that
he's confronted he talks about how
deeply catholic he is he still pays that
same lip service to a tradition that
he's not really religiously part of
yeah he feels he's compelled to do so
but not by religious forces he's not
doing it because he's like well my god
is the true god it's doing it because he
wants to be elected he's doing it yeah
he is not conventional
yeah he knows that the prince has to be
nominally religious in order for the
people to to like him like he he read
his renaissance politics he knows
what's going on but like when we talked
about when you talked about the let's
say the hindu system
you know the original hindu system would
have been the notion that the spiritual
element is the highest right and so the
priestly caste is the highest caste and
it doesn't have uh
military might so that's what
legitimizes the power of the state is
that you have a spiritual power that
doesn't have
that is only supposed to be turned
upwards towards the highest things they
don't have uh political they're not
supposed to have political and military
power so the military finds their
justification for their
military power in the spiritual
tradition
now the problem is that if you make
religion
like relative to all the individuals
then the only thing left to justify
the only thing left that's ultimately
going to bring about milit
civic unity would be something like
brute power
because it's not always interesting but
that's but that's the truth of the way
that it always has been the priestly
class has always relied upon the consent
of the militaries and the governments
anyway unless they're twain unless you
have an outright theocracy in which
they're the ones doing the governing and
the religions of side hustle what i
would say is that it's still it's it's
effectively the illusion of a benevolent
detached priestly
class and that actually is a problem
it's not the breakdown of traditions or
anything like that because of the
availability of different spiritual
systems because those spiritual systems
were never actually in control the
leaders typically
they would they would walk the walk and
talk the talk but only to a very short
extent they would say pray like like us
leaders they'll say praise jesus
get the evangelicals to vote for them
then you look at their voting record you
compare it to any proper interpretation
of christian canon and it tells an
entirely different story yeah and what
would i mean the way that it
what i mean is that so
let's say
let's let's look at the difference you
know between let's say the syrian empire
and
you know the worst even of christian
the christian colonialism and so the
syrian empire
just came in brutus brutally killed and
raped and took and did whatever the hell
it wanted and justified it by its
strength only that is there was no need
to say there was no need to pretend like
no need to to say like you know to at
least put out an image of being nice and
just and let's say having the the
christian values
and then doing something else in the
back what you see in christianity is
that people will project at least the
christian values and then in this in
secret do the bad things you know try to
get away with the bad things but and
that's that's
what's leading is still
an ideal like even if it's not
completely followed upon like it so
that's what i mean by the idea that the
invisible like the spiritual
world
leads the physical world and so even if
the even if let's say the roman popes
were all
lectures and and and whatever
they still held they still had to hold a
certain ideal and the aristocracy had a
an ideal which was let's say the
chivalrous ideal is something that you
don't find the idea of like the the
night that helps the the weak is
something that is just not there in the
roman times and it's just not there in
germanic
in german unless you think that that's
not the idea that should be held the
idea of like the strong helping the weak
let's say but that's a that's something
that holds
that's what i mean when i say that
the spiritual has to be above the
the civic authorities even if in
practice the leaders don't necessarily
follow it yeah but then that becomes a
problem because it becomes useful fodder
for propaganda if you've congealed the
society and there aren't those
differences of opinion that difference
in thought about spiritual topics and
stuff there won't be as much debate to
potentially shine upon those leaders who
aren't even acting they're not acting
for a god or anything they're acting in
their own self-interest or in what they
conceive of as the nation's interest and
they'll justify it it's sort of like the
debate we have right now
about coven
now i won't get too too deeply into it
because of course this is going to go on
youtube so we have to choose our words
carefully yeah exactly because because
susan weiziki is our is our deity here
uh
but look look at the public response
it's presented with a facade of this is
for your own good this is for
keeping people safe helping society and
stuff but the things that are actually
done don't comport in in all essences to
that actual goal the patriot act is a
great example i constantly default to
even the label patriot actor had nothing
to do with patriotism it was presented
as a way to keep people safe but it was
really a way to spy on people it's a
misrepresentation the problem is that
when you have that congealing of society
where the super majority of people
follow one ideology that ideology will
inevitably prevent potential actual
reformists who are outside of it from
becoming leaders that's problem number
one problem number two allow charlatans
who are simply charismatic within that
grouping to take power and to use it
and for their own benefit it's sort of
like what stalin did stalin works his
way up the rungs of the communist party
deviates entirely from what we could
consider at least at the very outset to
be an attempted reform because people
were suffering under czarism um and then
goes on to kill 20 million people well
it's all for your own good i'm going to
take these cool acts move them off their
land it's for they that they shouldn't
have that land uh they stole it or
something we're going to take a bunch of
ethnic russians moving to ukraine and
ship the ukrainians to the middle of
siberia why well it's it's because we
need to break these people apart to to
move closer to a communist collective
all of these things were presented under
the ideology that was professed to be
good things and instead they caused
untold suffering famine and pain for
many many people yeah but there's a
there is a difference between
ideology
and traditional
religion that is let's say if you ask
what's the what's the ideology of
christianity it's not it's not a
practical ideology per se
right it's a it's a it's a notion that
it's an idea of worship of the highest
good
and then that brings about certain
virtues and certain values and then
there are obviously ideology the only
difference is that you're claiming a
divine origin for what is uh can only be
construed of as a human ideology because
it involves humans involved in that
behavior
it's still an ideology it's just it
claims
it doesn't claim the ideology is
promulgated by force or by a collective
will it claims that it's enforced by a
deity that's up in space somewhere
nothing stays somewhere
no that's what the evil minds thought
yeah well they didn't think it i don't
think they think it the way you thought
you think they did you know when you
read dante he he mocks people who think
that the
that the uh
that the let's say that the spiritual
beings actually inhabit the heavenly
spheres he says no it's a it's a
condescension of divine language for our
understanding like the the spiritual
beings don't actually inhabit the
heavenly spheres it's a it's like it's
it's basically an a system of analogy
that helps you see
the higher realities that are invisible
realities and so believe in the
all-encompassing god then it would be in
the heavenly spheres but it would also
be
intertwined with everything else so yeah
definitely and that's that's
sort of like the force maybe we should
all just become jedis
yeah that would be super practical yeah
but in terms of what you're saying
that's the way it's especially in the
orthodox tradition that the way it's
understood that is god is both
absolutely transcendent and absolutely
imminent at the same time because he is
the
he is the thing he is that which holds
the world together let's say the bonding
you could say that the the world holds
together through the divine love is the
best way to understand it and that
everything i would yeah i would say if
you believe if you believe in the total
inner penetrating imminent god
that also and this is actually in the
bible it creates good and evil and is
sort of passive and all-encompassing
then i would say the best thing to do is
not worry too much about schisms and
civic things anyway because ultimately
it's just you know this amorphous
being's will and doesn't matter so much
and it would be mostly a statement of
individuality on that end anyway because
you would simply be professing your
faith doing your thing and living
according to what you believe is holy
and and godly
but there's a way in which we have to
like not only we have to but human
beings manifest like communal bodies
like we have to join together you know
we we join together in
in in in communal
versions of what we are it is you are
like
you are an amalgamation of stuff right
you know and so and that has to hold
together or else you're schizophrenic
like if you let the parts of you rule
you too much then you're you're you're
diseased and so we do the same like we
come together
and then we create
let's say
higher versions of what we are like
where we participate in communities and
bodies and that that has to that can't
only be to brought down to the
individual level can it
well it can
if the individuals i i argue from a
pragmatic perspective and say if the
individuals understand critical thinking
the individuality aspect is prime the
civic and religious aspects are more
decentralized and and the civic aspect
legal one is less important if you argue
the transcendent nature of a deity the
all-encompassing nature the good and the
evil the light and the dark the
everything and nothing at the same time
sort of imminence argument then i would
say it doesn't really matter if the
world ultimately goes to hell your your
soul is safe
ultimately everything that happens is
part of that divine will or lack of will
anyway
and it doesn't really matter and then i
would also i would also argue a proper
construing of you know the words of
jesus and the new testament would beg to
differ as well and essentially become
completely passive towards all civic
affairs and is almost quasi-separatist
in nature allowing people to form if if
they share your religious views those
communities on the outskirts and if
they're persecuted they're all the
better for it and they're martyrs yeah
but there there's a way there's a way in
which
i think what you're saying is that how
can i say this if god is the all is
imbibes all things then we participate
in
the world that is it doesn't make it
doesn't become this kind of less affair
thing where everybody
it so let's say in st paul there's this
idea that we are
that through bonds of love
then we create
let's say something like the body of god
in the world that is we we are the ones
who make the world
uh
something which holds together rather
than something that breaks apart so
but why would that be important in the
civic sense ultimately uh you would be
spending your time let's say that you've
got a societal reform on your mind you
make videos about it you march you do
activism or whatever would that not
technically be time that you're taking
away from doing what the explicit
command was which is to go give things
to the poor
and help the widows and stuff and you're
trying to help society at large
that society if you follow the example
of your christ effectively is nullified
there was no real attempt to reform
society it was individuals that were
being interacted with the only
interaction in the collective sense of
node is going in with a scourge and
attacking a bunch of uh bankers
which also is is something we can't
openly explicitly support that again
because this will be on youtube but it
is an interesting story yeah but there
there
there is the idea that christ gave the
idea of communion is not something which
just limits people to the to if you read
the chap the chapter then saying the
gospel saying john he keeps talking
about unity he keeps talking about like
you know be one as your father in heaven
as i
and one with my father all of this idea
of like a bond of unity and love uh and
so you're right that it's not something
which is
political per se and i think that that's
also why
the christian ideal is is more something
like
the the the saint or the monk or the
martyr
but then out of that will flow certain
societies that his societies will flow
out of that it doesn't create
um
how can i say this
so it really is in this sense that i was
talking about this hierarchy of being
that you have the brahmin and those that
fight and etc so if you recognize the
the monks and the saints as the highest
and they're the ones who do the things
you're saying because not everybody's
going to end up doing that the world
kind of lays itself out in normal
hierarchies like it just kind of flows
out but at the top of your hierarchy is
someone who gave everything for the poor
if the top of your hierarchy is someone
who gave everything for others then
there's a good chance that some of that
will flow down into the world
as and so i agree that like the civic
part is definitely not the top like it's
not the highest aspect um but it can
flow out of it but then the dysfunction
of the world would be properly more
ascribed to the sickness of organized
religion than anything else because it's
already there maybe in a degraded form
but what allowed it to degrade
would allow what do you mean would allow
weapons
if the civic is to be subjugated
entirely to the religious the religious
is is held up at the height which until
the last half century generally it was
in most countries anyway
and things are degrading wouldn't it
have to start at the top at the root of
the problem would be the religious
leaders no you're right you're
absolutely right and that's why if you
read
uh so then if the lord allows them to be
degraded and it's not certainly not just
the case in christianity it's the case
in any religious or spiritual movement
including among most pagan movements um
then then why entrust them with greater
power or try to organize society on
their basis if they're already sick
you'd need an entire revolution no but
that's why you in the in this traditions
you always have two strains you'll have
uh like a you'll have a saints strain
and then you'll have an official strain
and the real strain is the saints strain
that is the saints don't have to be
bishops or priests they can they don't
have to be popes they are recognized
they are recognized by the church by the
by the people by the the bond of love as
being representing the ideal and they're
the ones that really give us the the way
to go that then you have the hierarchy
let's say the actual civic verb like the
let's say the official version of the
hierarchy where you have priests and
bishops and everything and those are
needed and useful but ultimately those
are
they they have to bow to the saints
right they have to worship they have to
venerate the saints
because the saints are the one are not
part of that hierarchy you know and the
hierarchy is supposed to flow out of it
it degenerates i agree it of course it
does like every any human system it ends
up degenerating but it has in it the
possibility of keeping those ideals up
there like the ideals are clearly marked
and you know like what you're what
you're following
whereas like in in a like that's why i
if you look at what's going on in the
u.s i feel like that's the main issue is
that there is nothing
there's no spiritual example that is
keeping us together
right what is keep what is making us
something like what is making the united
states something
my memory of it's descending maybe yeah
the civic example of its founding was
based upon certain spiritual precepts
not all of which were christian that
part definitely the saints of
christendom would play a huge role not
in the religious sense but in what
you're saying the metaphoric sense
though again though pagan ideology was
intertwined and also secular ideology
that had been delivered through things
that are
logic philosophy in the more secular
sense although again that's intertwined
with religion mostly and things now
we're seeing what we're seeing exactly
that we're seeing a kind of taking down
of the saints of the of the united
states history oh yeah there's a reason
why they want to remove thomas jefferson
and so what what like what do we like
that's i guess that's the idea is like
how do we deal with this like how do you
deal with
i mean i we have the same problem like
i'll be honest with you like i have the
same problem in christianity you're
seeing the same thing happen right the
pope of rome
right now like is is is is acting
against the pedophile yeah
against the very foundations of a lot of
the foundations of his own
i've got a solution and it actually kind
of is the the christian prescription for
it at least in the sense of jesus
teachings which is decentralization
don't rely on public education it won't
teach your kid critical thinking
homeschool your kid or at the very least
get tutors grow your own food get to
know your neighbors form your local
communities create syndicates
decentralize your income do everything
that you can to be self-sufficient and
starve the machine because the real
problem is globalism is that the problem
the biggest problem is it goes beyond
just the united states it's an
international phenomenon at this point
that's actually an advantage in one way
because you can tell people of different
religions look it doesn't matter which
god you're worshiping you're still going
to be a slave to so we need to get it
out but it's one of the problems with
decentralization is that in the process
of decentralization it makes you weaker
because you're fragmented and so you end
up being a bunch of fragmented bits
facing this massive machine
and i'm saying this like i'm not trying
to get you or anything like that but if
you're
think about it as a puzzle so you get a
puzzle of 500 pieces and you only take
two or three out now the puzzle's bigger
but now let's say that most of the
pieces are absent well that puzzle is
not so formidable anymore it looks like
swiss cheese that's the way to do it you
need enough decentralization and i would
say pseudo decentralization in the
communications era because these groups
can coordinate with one another even at
great distances even across the entire
world they'd communicate with a lunar
colony if they wanted to
these decentralized groups but what
unites them together i guess hatred of
the system
yeah the fact that they want
individualism they want an end to the
abuse and tyranny of this of the world
system as it is which really it only
benefits a handful of crooks at the top
and none of these none of those people
are religious some people blame religion
to say like well it's these
these greedy uh christians running this
country these greedy sheiks islamists
running another one the jews the hindu
cast or something no these people don't
believe in any god
if they if they believed in the concept
of judgment or hell or purgatory or
karma or reincarnation they wouldn't act
the way they do because they'd be
terrified all the time
yeah i don't think i don't they're not
necessarily atheistic but they've just
they're completely clouded by
self-interest they don't even think
spiritual thoughts they're completely
apathetic towards them yeah they they
worship mammon basically is what we've
got they wouldn't even worship mammon
it'd require too much effort
i just care about i have to i have to
walk up these 50 steps just to throw the
baby on the altar what the [ __ ]
too much exercise i'll have my secretary
do it yeah there you go
um and so look i mean i think i think we
we've gone quite a quite a while i guess
maybe like uh
my last question for you would be
something like
in the past let's say 10 years or the
the past time that you've been on
youtube i've noticed that
strangely enough you do have a lot of
christian people that follow what you're
doing and you know you also moved it
seems from this kind of satanist kind of
a you know secular satanist type
position to now a more which seems to me
like a more nuanced position and so
i'm curious to see if you
if there are some aspects in these last
few years of christianity that you've
reconciled yourself with but if you
still think that it's really useless
oh well the majority of the more modern
works that i edit they were written by
christians more or less religious inform
i just did a work on mystic christianity
actually only about a week ago
i have an appreciation for anything that
i believe falls under the umbrella of
the occult any mystic tradition
christianity kabbalah mystic islamic
sufism those all fall under that
umbrella as well i don't
in the past i had more of a
problem with organized religion and took
it out on the religion itself
and in time what i realized is while
it's really greedy leaders i mean they
could also be greedy secular leaders it
really depends on the interpretation
more of the religion what i would say is
the fire and brimstone aspect of some
groups of christendom i oppose i think
that it's crazy but then it's no
different than the fire and brimstone
style groups that you find in any uh
hyper zealous community it's the same in
all religions there are pagans like that
there are pagans that probably probably
would revert to human sacrifices if they
were legally capable of doing it and
getting away with
the actual devil warship cults out there
that do crazy [ __ ] too uh one thing that
i would like to point out for the
benefit of your audience is going on
your channel is i am not a satanist some
people believe that i still am that was
ten years ago and that was a
transformative atheistic step to
clearing my mind out before i indulged
in all religions and i could look at
them with a clear lens it was sort of
like a wiping of the lens for me um
even the term pagan though
at this point i don't know is fully
appropriate for me due to practice it's
really occultism yeah it's a it's a
search for what is hidden or what is not
known more than anything else i'm just
on the road with everybody else i just
don't think there is an end destination
maybe i find one someday but i'm not
looking for it i'm just looking for the
different paths and enjoying myself on
the way
well i would say then i would still i
would recommend that you look into
uh
hesi chasm like the the christian the
eastern mystical practice which is which
is completely it's very similar to uh to
other mystical practices but in that
it's not secret that is it is it is
integrated into into the church there's
a there's a compiled book called the the
philocalia which is a kind of
compilation of all these mystical texts
which talk about the mystical practice
breathing techniques you know attention
to the heart uh posture and then uh
repetitive prayer all of these things
that you find so it's like yoga so see
it is like hinduism uh i mean it's
obviously it's not it's not it's not the
same but it is definitely a spiritual
practice which looks more
like eastern practices than it does the
kind of emotional
you know gospel worship you'll have to
link you'll have to link me to that book
where i can get it i'll definitely think
and i'd still i think i mentioned it on
our last song i would suggest you read
uh my my brother's book his name is matu
pejo he wrote a book called the language
of creation and uh he actually he
actually watches your content so he was
excited when i told him that that uh
that i was gonna talk to you but i think
that he can bridge also some ideas
in terms of uh
in terms of like let's say the the
esotericism
and
a way of understanding it in a
in a way that isn't hostile to
to that's one of my biggest problems i
think with the occult is that the man in
which he became hostile to
to
normal religious religious practice you
could say like where
you had this elite that were practicing
these things and then the people
is like it's it's actually in a way that
you phrase it yourself it's like ah for
the masses this stuff and then for the
really the the the elites this stuff and
it's that separation which i find
difficult well the positive side of that
was an attempt to bring the masses
upward and make everyone sort of aware
of that occult nest the theosophists
were big for this social reform and so
forth some of which actually took off
and and were promulgated including
prohibition sorry for that one say this
theosophists uh
unfortunately there are some occultists
that are just completely elitist though
and they don't think anyone can learn
unless they've been given the the mark
of solomon or something like that like
they have to be like marked at birth
especially with special star signs or
something in order to learn magic and
i'm like
i don't think so
all right well anyways thanks for the
conversation i i appreciated it and uh
like we'll see how people react to this
conversation if you want we could always
uh
pursue it so yeah it was great all right
cool nice to talk to you we'll say peace
out all right bye-bye
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support